[Music]
happy friday greets you between mejía and
this is your brief news of the day you
are the one who has reported about two
dozen earthquakes in the night in the
center of nevada one of the places
where it was most felt was on the outskirts  of
tone to start at 4 in the
morning the first however was the
largest with a magnitude of 6.5
damages are reported on
highway 95 and 360
the tremor could have been felt here
in las vegas people on twitter said they
felt it when  north rino and others
in sacramento california
a photographer from fresno took this video
and the restaurants in the bay have
returned to operations but not
those inside the casinos for the
time being on thursday nevada gaming control
created new rules to
allow you  for the restaurants inside
the casinos to open their doors
again, they must first follow the
rules granted by the governor,
people would also have to enter
and leave  from the restaurant have access to the
use of bathrooms but without stepping on the
playground
and on the other hand they installed new grass
in the stadium bank didn't our ground
captured this incredible video just watch
this one it will remain in the south part at the
end of the stadium to then slide it
onto the playing field construction is expected to
be completed by july and
las vegas' turns 115 today happy
birthday here we show you some
pictures of the digital library of the
university in albi today but
in 1905 here 110 acres of land  what
is now downtown was acquired by a
railway company, however, it did not
begin to be populated until 1931
when the casinos and theaters were
built to entertain the
workers building the hub
and now we go to your weather forecast
for the  weekend we will be
in the low
90 degrees for today friday with
sunny skies for saturday and sunday
we will continue with the heat above
the 90's
, however, the winds return for
Monday with lower temperatures have
a great weekend and take care of yourself I
'm héctor mejía and this was your brief
news on youzhny in spain'
[Music]